what's with the jeans in his language
but that's the package the FedEx package
is here does anybody dog is the worst
stuff you wanna dogs
it's a Brussels Griffon beautiful little
girl really sweet animal you'll see her
in a pillowcase floating down the LA
River at about 7 a.m. go ahead and pick
that up it's your dog or it's your dog
she might be on the 405 freeway at the
Santa Monica exit yeah just waiting just
kind of hanging out can I tell you with
this dog if anybody out there if you're
a real dog trainer and don't fucking
email me if you're not legit our dog
eats everything in the backyard and I
mean everything rocks glass pieces
she's indiscriminate I mean it and we're
lucky she's still alive frankly but now
whatever the fuck she's eating our
backyard is giving her diarrhea and
she's had diarrhea twice in the last two
weeks and it was we don't know what to
do either we muzzle her when we look at
my area yeah I don't know how to keep
her from eating you know whatever the
fuck it is and it's everything
everything in anything I don't know what
to do I'm at a loss yeah it's worse a
fireplace we can put it in there here's
your new crate get in the grade better
be hey we're gonna turn it on she would
just go family she wouldn't eat the fire
she went up we turn on the fireplace she
went right up to it and was like yeah
she almost did start licking the fire
she's so inbred and stupid gorgeous dog
designer dog dumbest dog we ever had
thief from Downey from the streets
smartest never runs away wouldn't dream
of running away because he knows how
hard it is No